بعد ما انتظرت هذه اللحظه 40 عاما احتضنت
والده الاسير الحاجه وداد يونس البالغ من
العمر
88 عاما نجلها اليوم لاول مره
شعور لا لا يوصف بعيد 40 سنه
اولاد العم واصدقاء الصباح بعد ان امضيات
طفولتهما سويا
زملاء في السجن لاربعين عاما اليوم
يلتقيان وهما يتنفسان الحريه
هذا شعور لا يوصف وان كنا يعني لا يمكن
الوصفه يعني كل اللغه العربيه لا يمكن وصف
الشعور هذا ايه شعور طبعا طيب والاستقبال
ما شاء الله الحمد لله شفت الاهل وشفت
الاصدقاء ومن عاشروني في الاسير يعني كمان
انا وماهر اصدقاء كنت انا بالبيت عندهم
وهو من بيت عنا واحنا كمان تعلمنا سوا في
نفس المدرسه والاخره وتغربنا سواء وكمان
رفاق نضال يعني زميل او صديق مشترك
وحسناتنا
انه يمكن نزور بيوت اسرى اخرين حنظرهم ان
شاء الله سوا بعد ان وجهها ماهر رساله
للشعب الفلسطيني
التي تهتف باسمي فلسطين
عشرات الفلسطينيين اتو من القدس وام الفحم
وعكا والمدن المجاوره لتقديم التهاني
والتبريكات للاسير ماهر يونس على الرغم من
قرار وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اتمرن
كبير منع مظاهر الاحتفال ورفع الاعلام
الفلسطينيه احتفل عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
بتحرير الاسير ماهر يونس والذي امضى
اربعين عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه لا
نكون غازي من قريه عراء العربيه